[Musique]
le président à prendre
j'arrive enfin les quilles au maillet
deux étapes stylisme suite de maquillage
et et et c'est vrai ça accentue notre
photo votre shopping à ses côtés au non
j'ai pas trop besoin même si j'ai pris
un peu collant des dacquois de choisir
non non très bon
ça on l'a fait a fait le vestiaire
forfait merci mon dieu si nous faisions
une caméra cachée caméra là dedans et ne
sont que nous avons eu nous ont fait
venir une araignée je file mais bon
heureusement montre parfois notre match
a alors unités l'upr un sentier de ce
qu'on pouvait une tête le chien qu'une
coiffure qu'on ne fait plus aujourd'hui
des mines perry a tourné une séquence
d'un certain stéphane bur alors sera
t-elle diffusé je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas elle a été mise en place
pendant une semaine j'ai j'ai perdu
confiance en moi c'est ma force et ma
protection
oui ça m'a fait le visage bouffi au
chômage et la barbe dans le film et ça
excellent
j'ai pris ces propos fait ben brik
souffre en ce moment
[Musique]
m
ensuite en partant à heures donc
naturisme
encore une toute l'année
c'est vraiment si j'étais cuit hier
devant la glace et la maison 2h30
maj2 à présent qui ne sert jamais
vraiment beaucoup on ne parle jamais
dans l'oreillette matériel d'urgence
atteignent y est c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
bon allez c'est la fin d'une semaine se
termine et ça s'est super bien passé
allez c'est parti mon secret
[Musique]